next up
here's a little something you might like
this is a game watch system that lets
you play
three games in the legend of zelda
series this year
the original legend of zelda game
reaches its 35th anniversary
while we don't have any campaigns or
other nintendo switch games planned
we've been working on this game watch
system as a special item to help mark
the occasion
and reflect fondly on the earliest days
of the legend of zelda
it will come with the first game in the
series the legend of zelda
zelda 2 the adventure of link
and the game boy version of the legend
of zelda link's awakening game
as well as a special version of the game
watch title vermin
starring link as the playable character
so that's four games on one system
from longer legend of zelda games to the
pick up and play game vermin
in addition regarding the watch
functionality for the game watch system
we've added a playable clock based on
the legend of zelda
and an interactive timer themed after
zelda 2 the adventure of link
[Music]
you can play with both of them by taking
control of link
[Music]
we hope you'll enjoy playing this game
and watch system whenever and wherever
you'd like